So when it comes to preferences versus core values,
um,
what do you put under preference and what do you put under core values?
Right. Oh, so,
so in general preferences can be your,
you know what I'm just saying that attractiveness, height, build,
yeah. Um,
complection. It is seen someone,
some people are like strictly to say no children,
you might find the perfect person,
but if they say I have a child,
Aah, no,
the guy says no. Um,
core values, of course we come to your,
to your beliefs. Are you,
are you a Christian? Um,
are you family orientated?
You know, are you kind,
those kind of values that you say that's,
that's part of a person. Yeah.
Right. So as,
as, as,
as, as single men,
as single men, what,
how do you balance that? You know,
what can you compromise and what can you not?
Okay. I think everything has to do with your,
your date first when you go for a date
because the reason why you go and date,
go for a date is because you wanna know and understand that
that particular person, just to interject you there,
would you, would you consider a date
for someone who does not meet your preferences?
Then, then of course date is when you know, the,
start to know the core values.
But initially there, if that person does not fit your initial criteria
or initial preference, yeah,
it definitely starts with the preferences.
Because you don't go on a date with a girl
before you ask her on a date, right?
In order to ask her on a date,
she has to be attractive to you physically. The,
and this is visual, right?
So before you even know if she's kind or whatever,
you look at her body and her face and her bills, right?
The way she carries herself,
the way she walks, the way she talks,
those things. That's where the preference, uh,
arena is, right?
Um, so I think if you're clear what it is that you are attracted to,
it makes it so much easier.
I used to believe that I, I didn't have,
you know, a type, a type.